à tout seigneur tout honneur d'abord la
reine d'angleterre en france d'ailleurs
saumon sur tapis rouge
c'est un accueil en grande pompe qui a
été réservé à la reine elizabeth 2 pour
son troisième voyage officiel en france
dès son arrivée à orly la souveraine
britannique a réaffirmé avec force et en
français l'attachement de son pays à
l'europe troisième visite d'état je vous
le disais la première en 57 sous rené
coty la deuxième en mai 72 o philippe
harrouard était déjà à la rtf difficile
en 1972 de distinguer la couleur des
atours de la reine reçu par georges
pompidou
vingt ans plus tard pas de problème
c'est l'abricot qui domine la petite
histoire remarquera qu elisabeth ii
vient à paris le jour de la fin diane
diana en anglais pur hasard
la grande histoire retiendra que les
premières paroles royal sont un credo
européen qui ne peut que séduire son
hôte
françois mitterrand la grande reine à sa
place au coeur de l'europe et l'avenir
de l'europe se confond avec le sien
c'est seulement en étant étroitement
liés à la france qu'elle pourra tirer le
meilleur parti des ouvertures et des
chances que lui offre l'europe
harris est une lumière qui scintille
dans les imaginations
il est déjà elizabeth il y a vingt ans
aujourd'hui la ville lumière a tenu ses
promesses vous recevoir et acclamé le
couple royal qui se rend à pied de sa
résidence de l'hôtel de marigny au
palais de l'elysée cet après midi
changement de tenue jaune canari oblige
pour une promenade en bateau sur le
bassin de la villette en route vers la
cité des sciences
tiens tiens jacques lang en profite pour
réviser son anglais
en tout cas visite studieuse de la
france contemporaine et inventive
finalement il avait deux ne se sent pas
dépaysé ici elle a même retrouvé le
rarissime cabriolet utilisé il y a vingt
ans et on dira que les français ne sont
pas conservateur
plusieurs milliers de parisiens de
touristes s'étaient massés sur les
champs elysées vers midi pour acclamer
la souveraine
même le soleil était de la fête et parmi
les badauds extasié bernard lebrun
dernière répétition pour le salut à la
reine qui a eu la géniale idée de
remonter la plus belle avenue du monde
à l'heure du déjeuner j'étais très
nerveux regarde à cheval pour laval 0
contre c'est quand même la grand-papa
rate mais si mais si madame la parra
sera à la hauteur de l'événement soyez
rassurés pas facile il est vrai de voir
quelque chose entre deux panneaux
publicitaires les marchands de périscope
en carton ont disparu avec les foules
d'antan lui garder là avec un peu de
chance
chacun pourra apercevoir sa majesté en
compagnie du président de la république
attention regardez bien petit signe de
la main inexorablement la décapotable
avance c'est fini
vous avez pu voir la reine est là mais
elle avait un chapeau oui
ah ouais un chapeau et puis il ya ceux
qui sont bloqués et s'offre une pause
contraint et forcé vous avez quelque
chose vous avez vu passer quelque chose
vous attendez quoi là avant il faut que
les chevaux organes l'écurie poursuivi
images étonnantes par ces drôles de
machines verte
les balayeuses ramasseur de crottes
nettoyer les champs elysées son gré
ouvert la reine est passé livreur
traverse la vie continue avec la reine
d'angleterre une autre elizabeth est
l'héroïne du jour elisabeth guigou
ministre des affaires européennes qui va
tenir ce soir à sélestat à sur les
enjeux de maastricht un meeting commun
avec valéry giscard d'estaing au total
une dizaine de meetings rassemblant des
mini sous des responsables socialistes
et des dirigeants de l'udf sont prévus
d'ici la fin de ce mois cette initiative
du mouvement européen a provoqué hier
soir la colère de l'état major du rpr
qui a publié dans la soirée un
communiqué mettant en demeure valéry
giscard d'estaing et les dirigeants de
l'udf de renoncer à ces réunions
publiques sous peine de conséquences
graves pour l'union de l'opposition
l'ancien président de la république a
décidé de maintenir sa venue pour le
meeting de sélestat il s'en est expliqué
il ya quelques minutes auprès de nos
confrères de fr3 qui lui ont rappelé que
leur père l'accusé en quelque sorte
donné un coup de main au président de la
république s'agit pas de françois
mitterrand il s'agit du traité de
maastricht alors tout de même pas à
baisser dégradé le débat politique en
france avec les français sont très lassé
du comportement de leur classe politique
et il souhaite que les hommes politiques
l'on parle des problèmes qui se posent
alors il ya trois mois on avait la
campagne des régionales
je suis resté en auvergne et j'ai parlé
aux auvergnats de l'avenir de notre
région
la région devient ton à voter mais c'est
d'avoir gagné là nous avons un traité
qui est important pour la france pour la
france pas pour les partis politiques
pour les français leur vie quotidienne
leur avenir les jeunes et les français
ne savent pas quel est le contenu de ce
traité nous allons leur expliquer de
façon contradictoire alors
ensuite à l'automne il y aura un
référendum et pour ce référendum l'udf
fera sa propre campagne sous ses propres
couleurs avec ses propres valeurs
je propose de rejoindre tout de suite
sélestat cette petite ville du bas-rhin
qui va peut être laisser son nom dans
l'histoire contemporaine que mon vif des
militants dans la tente de ce meeting
tout à fait inédit reportage d'olivier
werner et bruno girodon pour chirac
crise car la route qui conduit à
maastricht est décidément bien
compliquée pour l'opposition
pour la première fois en france les pros
maastricht de gauche comme de droite se
retrouvent face à face ou plutôt côte à
côte
une première qui fait du bruit à paris
mais qui vu d'alsace n'émeut pas outre
mesure les européens du ps et de l'udf
dans deux mois ils vont se taper dessus
pour les législatives aujourd'hui son
ensemble sur sur le même bord je trouve
que c'est pas très logique
je trouve qu'on devrait tous se mettre
d'accord pour que ça avance correctement
et sans kit débat intérieur
c'est un peu choquant peu surréaliste
que de voir une personnalité de gauche
et de droite sur une même estrade
c'est tout juste intelligent pourquoi
vous construire l'europe il faut qu'on
soit ensemble et qu'on élimine la
politique intérieure a fait écouter et
applaudir
madame guigou ministre des affaires
européennes ça je ne sais pas je suis
toujours libre de mes idées je ne sais
pas ce qu'elle dit ou n'importe quoi je
ne peux pas le dire d'avant qu'il faut
d'abord que j'écoute
ils sont venus s'instruire avant tout le
traité de maastricht est en vente dans
cette salle 66 francs et il se vend
comme des petits pains pendant ce
temps-là paris les sénateurs reprenez
l'examen de la révision
constitutionnelle préalable vous savez à
la ratification du traité d'union
européenne après le vote négatif des
danois au référendum un certain nombre
de sénateurs dont charles pasqua estime
qu'il n'y a plus lieu à débattre les
socialistes et les centristes sont de
l'avis contraire sur place reportage
unique saint olive le sénat à la fièvre
de maastricht et la majorité udf rpr
manifeste en plus un symptôme aigu de
désunion
les premiers veulent aller de l'avant
les autres noms avant qu'il ne commence
et toujours ce plan parlementaire une
erreur qu'il est déraisonnable
d'ailleurs contraire au droit
international de reprendre ce débat je
reviens tout à l'heure est-ce que vous
avez une majorité qui pense la même
chose que vous des membres
mais de son côté roland dumas propose
une seule potion il faut avaler le
traité de maastricht telle qu'elle est
sans grimace alors les communistes
s'emballe le rpr réclament à grands cris
une suspension de séance
les centristes et les indépendants
veulent eux aussi se compter c'est la
dispersion
les sénateurs se retrouveront après le
dîner ou une discussion générale ou pour
une bataille de procédure la nuit de
toute façon sera longue
au palais du luxembourg l'organisation
de ces dix meetings communs ps udf pour
défendre le traité d'union politiques
européens signent à maastricht suscite
de sérieux remous dans les états majors
politiques nous y reviendrons tout à
l'heure avec nos invités alain juppé sur
ce plateau et simone veil qui est à
strasbourg où rpr jacques chaban delmas
a décidé d'annuler sa participation au
meeting de bordeaux qui était prévu avec
roland dumas et jean françois poncet par
loyauté at il dit à l'égard du rpr grand
également au ps où jean poperen qualifie
cette campagne commune de tout à fait
surprenante jean poperen qui réclame une
convocation d'urgence du comité
directeur du ps affirme que ce que la
france retiendra c'est je cite le
spectacle des chefs de la droite et du
ps sur le même preto
cette addition de chef fera une
soustraction de voit tout de suite je
vous propose de retrouver gilles leclair
qui est l assemblée nationale pointe n 2
bataille rangée guérilla toujours est il
que le communiqué du rpr a provoqué un
étrange duel au sein de l'opposition
sans qu'on sache vraiment qui a dégainé
le premier
alors crise ou pas aux censeurs chinois
il y accuse c'est à dire c'est à dire
qu'on est en train de préparer une
opportunité vision optimiste de ceux qui
ne veulent pas dramatiser en attendant
c'est bien chacun de son côté que l'on
s'est réuni cet après midi sans vraiment
évolué et les échanges sont restés rares
objective wall avait tenu depuis deux
mois
c'est à entraîner le maximum des
responsables de l'opposition sur la
ratification et c'est mon seul objectif
nous sommes toujours par muscu tobin
c'est très bien mais tous nos collègues
députés ont dit une chose simple
dans une démocratie où on est dans la
majorité où on est dans l'opposition on
peut pas avoir un pied dans chaque camp
un ultimatum ce n'est jamais bon cela
dit j'espère encore possible de
travailler pour entraîner le maximum de
responsables du rpr raboter la
ratification de maastricht
si les ponts ne sont pas coupés chacun
fait déjà ses comptes et mesurent
l'étendue des dégâts
sous l'oeil goguenard de quelques autres
il faut jamais se réjouir du malheur des
autres
simplement ce que je considère ces que
j'observe comme tous les français que la
droite est incapable de s'unir pour
quelque chose ce soir personnes non
encore prononcé le mot recomposition
mais chacun ne manquent pas disent
angers est d'être sur ses gardes
dernière réaction à noter celle du front
national qui demande aux dirigeants du
rpr de tenir des meetings communs avec
les amis de jean marie le pen pour
défendre l'europe des patries et le non
au référendum
maintenant le problème du rpr s'est
enfin d'avoir une position sur l'europe
alors ou bien ils sont pour maastricht
et après tout ils font des meetings avec
le parti socialiste
ou bien ils sont contre maastricht et
pourquoi pas tenir meeting avec le front
national qui lui de tout temps a été
contre maastricht moi pour ma part je
suis prêt à tenir meeting avec monsieur
seguin
monsieur pasqua qui auront tenu sur
cette question là des propos qu'ils sont
largement repris les propositions de
jean marie le pen du front national
à neuf mois des législatives de mars
prochain lors que jacques chirac et
valéry giscard d'estaing avait réaffirmé
sur tous les tons leur volonté
d'enterrer définitivement la hache de
guerre alors que l'opposition s'étaient
mises d'accord sur un processus de
désignation d'un candidat unique à la
présidentielle udf et rpr sont donc au
bord du divorce sur cette question
capitale pour l'avenir la construction
européenne récit d'un désamour avec
roland sicard et françois brabant avec
la participation tout à fait
involontaire de julio iglesias
m
et oui c'est ça giscard chirac 20 ans de
cohabitation quelques hauts et beaucoup
de bas tonné après les régionales il
était à tu et à toi même les vieilles
scènes de ménages sur les primaires
étaient oubliées c'était union union
union
et puis patatras maastricht est passée
par là chirac
ecoute-moi giscard et plus pascouau
séguin ils veulent un référendum
giscard n'en veut pas notre mouvement
chouette et je dirais exige qu'une telle
réforme soit adoptée par la voix du
révérend pourquoi un référendum
franchement mais la belle histoire
tourne au vinaigre pourtant il avait
l'occasion de se rabibocher puisque le
référendum aura lieu de toute façon mais
voilà maastricht toujours maastricht
giscard veut maintenant faire des
meetings en commun avec les membres du
ps chirac crie à l' infidélité à l'est
nous on le connaît le fin mot de
l'histoire ce qu'ils craignent c'est de
savoir comment tout cela va finir parce
que c'est bien connu
on a voulu faut toujours la compétence
j'ai eu la chance les gars
ce soir albert du roy c'est peut être le
président du parti radical il galant qui
résume le mieux la situation il affirmé
sur l'antenne de l'opposition est enfin
de gagner le championnat du monde de
masochisme politique
oui effectivement on savait depuis
longtemps que la droite comme la gauche
d'ailleurs mais elle dans une moindre
mesure que la droite était divisé sur le
traité d'union européenne
mais on savait aussi que ses principaux
leaders giscard chirac balladur léotard
juppé était globalement favorable à ce
traité du coup de stratégie était
possible la première consistait à
conduire le débat le plus vite possible
pour pouvoir évacuer rapidement ce sujet
de division
premier avantage si tous les liquides
les leaders prôné le vote favorable
le succès de louis serait la victoire de
l'europe et non celle de mitterrand
deuxième avantage personne ne pouvait
suspecter chirac de complaisance à
l'égard du chef de l'état il aurait été
impossible d'imaginer une manoeuvre de
politique intérieure le traité ratifié
l'opposition aurait pu repartir d'un
même pas à l'assaut des législatives
c'est la stratégie de banalisation
adoptée par l'udf
la deuxième stratégie celle de la
dramatisation consistait à mener la
guérilla parlementaire contre le
gouvernement mais alors le débat
traînaient en longueur la division de
l'opposition étaient de plus en plus
visible la question européenne et
l'affrontement gauche droite étant
mélangés
il devait impossible de dire oui à
l'europe sans que cela soit interprété
comme un oui à mitterrand c'est la
stratégie qu'a finalement choisi le rpr
sans doute chirac at il estimé qu'il
était plus bénéfique pour lui et pour le
rpr de privilégié l'affrontement franco
français plutôt que le consensus
européen mais cela ne pouvait que
l'éloigner de ceux pour qui l'europe est
une absolue priorité
merci albert avec nous en direct je vous
disais de strasbourg simone veil et puis
sur ce plateau à côté de voilà juppé
secrétaire général du rpr
première question à simone veil j'espère
que vous m'entendez bonsoir madame dans
soir jacques chirac tout à l'heure
devant ses amis du appert a dénoncé les
initiatives prises par certains
responsable de l'udf qui sont de nature
at il dit à réhabiliter le gouvernement
socialiste et françois mitterrand est ce
que vous ne pensez pas qu effectivement
la présence d'un ensemble de dirigeants
à commencer par celle de valéry giscard
d'estaing côtés de responsables
socialistes est de nature à troubler
profondément vos électeurs
je ne pense pas parce que ce dont nous
allons parler ceux qui seront appelés à
faire ce genre des réunions c'est
uniquement l'organisation de l'europe
ça n'est pas du tout ne s'agit pas des
choix que nous ferons pour les
politiques à mener en europe
c'est comme nous choisirons une
constitution pour l'europe
au fond on peut très bien concevoir que
sur le choix d'une constitution
tout le monde tout le monde soit
d'accord c'est ce qui s'est passé et à
plusieurs reprises par le passé en
france et que on lutte ensemble pour
faire admettre ce cadre et qu'il y ait
même discussions autour de ce cadre pour
faire bien comprendre que à l'intérieur
il peut y avoir des politiques qui sont
des politiques que tout à fait
différente et je m'imagine je pense
quand je suis amenée par exemple à faire
une réunion vendredi prochain avec
monsieur fabius et je pense que l'un
comme l'autre nous défendrons pour
l'europe des politiques qui peuvent être
différentes sur bien des sujets qu'il
s'agisse de la politique sociale ou
qu'ils s'agissent la politique monétaire
ou économique
nous n'avons pas certainement les mêmes
positions sur les politiques que
l'europe peut faire et d'ailleurs dans
actuellement en europe
il ya des gouvernements de tendances
très différentes mais dans le même cadre
institutionnel
or aujourd'hui ce qui nous apparaît
incertain non c'est de faire comprendre
qu'il est important d'adopter ce cadre
institutionnel voteront dans un instant
serait posé une question alain juppé je
vais vous demander pourquoi pourquoi si
tard alors que ses meetings sont prévus
depuis quelques jours maintenant est ce
que vous ne craignez pas à l'effet
dévastateur de cette dramatisation
subite sur l'opinion pourquoi si tard ça
commence aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
l'impression d'être en retard par
rapport à l'évènement sur un peu de cas
hier soir l'anair joueurs à la veille de
cette réunion c'était je crois le bon
moment ça et moi je suis en toute chose
partisans autant que faire se peut de la
clarté et je ne pense pas que le
distinguo un peu subtile si elle me le
permet avec madame veil vient
d'introduire soit de nature à favoriser
la clarté nous n'avons pas la même
conception de l'europe que les
socialistes et c'est tellement vrai
qu'il y à peine 10 jours à l'assemblée
nationale nous avons essayé ils ont
presque réussi de censurer la politique
agricole européenne du groupe
demant alors à quoi riment ces meetings
communs sinon à prendre le risque de
troubler les électrices et les électeurs
vous savez moi je suis pour l'europe
je suis prêt à ratifier maïs riche mais
en aucune manière à donner un coup de
main monsieur mitterrand parce que je
pense que plutôt les socialistes
quitteront le pouvoir mieux ça vaudra
pour mon pays alors vous savez bien tous
les sondages l'indiquent depuis des
années les français sont très tristes de
la bipolarisation le fait que la france
soit éternellement coupé en deux on
avait l'occasion de voir la fin de ces
clivages partisans
et puis on a l'impression que chacun on
revient à la case départ est ce que là
aussi vous pensez que les électeurs vont
comprendre ces crispations
vous n'êtes que les français sont très
triste je crois que ce sont les
commentateurs qui lança israël avait
risqué que de la bipolarisation
oui mais les français votent les
français votent ils ont voté aux
élections régionales ils ont voté aux
élections cantonales
et moi je ne connais pas de démocratie
qui fonctionne dans laquelle il n'y a
pas une majorité et une opposition c'est
même une des règles fondamentales de la
démocratie
lorsqu'il n'y a ni majorité ni
opposition on se retrouve dans un
système à l'italienne et la grande
innovation de la constitution de 58 le
grand acquis du gaullisme ça a été
précisément de permettre à un pays comme
la france d'être gouvernés alors il faut
parler des question de fond quel et
l'europe que nous voulons demain est ce
que c'est une europe socialiste ou est
ce que c'est une europe libérale
je suis sûr que madame veil veulent une
europe libérale et de ses l'europe de
giscard hiver oui merci c'est l'europe
de giscard pourquoi aller faire campagne
avec madame guigou
pourquoi les faire campagne avec
monsieur bérégovoy pourquoi les faire
campagne avec monsieur pesé comme
millions va le faire ceci c'est fille de
sens commun mais là je n'arrive pas à me
reconnaître et nous avons voulu dire
clairement les choses
je suis pour l'europe mais je ne ferai
pas campagne avec des socialistes simone
veil est ce que vous voulez le sentiment
d'être sur cette question plus près les
socialistes l'urbain je voudrais revenir
à une question qui va paraître tout à
fait fondamental c'est celle de la
clarté est justement ce dont ce que les
français doivent savoir lorsqu'ils vont
se prononcer pour le référendum
cette île ans à se prononcer non pas sur
les politiques qui seront faites une
heure à plus ou moins libéral et auront
à se prononcer sur l'architecturé sur la
construction sur les institutions
l'europe
on sait très bien que dans la contre la
constitution la cinquième elle a
successivement eu des gouvernements de
droite modérée
puis des gouvernants socialiste avec la
même constitution
aujourd'hui sur le référendum ne
choisiront pas la politique qui saura me
et dans cette europe nous choisirons les
la constitution de l'europe
j'ajoute d'ailleurs que c'est en fait je
comprends assez mal aujourd'hui qu'il y
ait tant de difficultés pour le rpr a
accepté cette nouvelle constitution
parce que elle est très proche de
l'actuel j'irai même qu'elle est
inscrite logiquement dans la tunique si
on voulait rester au traité de rome ne
pas aller plus loin il fallait refuser
l'acte unique mais c'est peut-être une
étape qui était timonen nécessairement
compte tenu de ce qui avait été décidé
en 1985 qui menait nécessairement à
renforcer les institutions
sauf à avoir quelque chose de tout à
fait incohérent sur le plan
constitutionnel cela dit dans ce cadre
il ya des gouvernements qui sont des
gouvernements socialistes il ya des
gouvernements qui sont des gouvernements
conservateurs comme en angleterre
demain ce sera peut-être les
travaillistes c'est toujours le même
cadre c'est là dessus que nous aurons à
voter et non pas du tout il faut pas
faire croire aux français que il en
dépendre un tel ou tel politique
agricole telle ou telle politique plus
ou moins libéral c'est tout à fait autre
chose
il s'agit d'une constitution c'est tout
et je pense que pour ma part il aurait
beaucoup mieux valu pour ne pas que ça
devienne justement un sujet de politique
intérieure puisque monsieur chirac lui
même disait qu'il souhaitait un
référendum et que à l'époque il
souhaitait ratifié maïs triche
à ce moment là il fallait dire eh bien
nous nous sommes d'accord avec ce table
et nous l'adoptons nous le votons sans
faire des difficultés comme il y en a eu
et probablement que ce serait déjà comme
ça a été fait dans certains pays
une étape qui est passé d'autres au
contraire par référendum je résume et
j'obtiens ce n'est pas prêt de plus il
est bas ce soir bien sûr on en tournait
quand je respecte mes dd semaine je
respecte tout à fait le point de vue non
oui le point de vue et madame veil mais
ça n'est pas le point de vue de tous
ceux qui soutiennent masri j'ai même
entendu des responsables éminent de
l'udf nous expliquer que le traité de
maastricht et l assurance tous risques
contre le socialisme ce qui prouve bien
que c'est le fond aussi qui est en cause
et pas simplement la constitution puis
je vais simplement rajouté un
commentaire je ne comprends pas pourquoi
on se précipite tellement dans cette
affaire parce que le traité de
maastricht
à l'heure actuelle mais il n'existe pas
il ya une nouvelle très importante qui
est tombée cet après midi le
gouvernement britannique souhaite pour
faciliter le retour dans la maison
communautaire
les danois un protocole additionnel qui
va jusqu'à limiter les pouvoirs de la
commission cela veut dire en réalité que
la négociation est ouverte à nouveau et
ce que nous disons avec je crois un peu
de bon sens c'est que dans ces
conditions il ne faut pas se précipiter
il faut connaître le traité dans sa
version définitive avant de prendre une
position également définitive si vous
devez juste un mot sur cette observation
mais vraiment je demanderais d'être bref
parce que comme bien menton délit mais
puisque paul delva soulanges entend de
la bouche de d'éminents membres du rpr
depuis un certain temps qu'il faut pas
se précipiter qu'on est les premiers or
les anglais en définitive ont voté bien
avant nous ont pas permis de la ville
n'ont pas terminé mais ça s'est passé à
la chambre s'est passé à la chambre des
communes très largement avec un large
soutien
alors qu'on a toujours dit nous avons
toujours considéré que les anglais
étaient de mauvaise européen on les a
toujours
brocardé sur ce thème et puis on
définitive c'est en france où je veux ce
que je ne comprends pas c'est que ceux
qui nous disent qu en définitive ils ont
ils sont d'accord vous dise en même
temps maintenant qu'ils ne sont pas
d'accord alors je crois que ce puisqu'on
parle de transparence et de clarté que
l'on sache qui est pour puisque tout de
même ceux qui ont été amenés à examiner
le texte à l'assemblée nationale
l'on regarde et il doit bien savoir
maintenant s'ils sont pour ou si son
compte et que c'est comme ça que veulent
les français peut-être comprendront un
petit peu de quoi il s'agit et quelles
sont les positions des uns et des autres
sans me répéter je voudrais quand même
fait observer que nous ne connaissons
pas la version définitive du texte et
que la révision mais non madame la d re
négociation est ouverte et nous allons
voir ce qui se passe à lisbonne où ce
qui se passe après et par ailleurs le
processus de révision constitutionnelle
est encore au sénat nous n'avons pas
abouti nous ne savons pas exactement
quelles sont les garanties définitives
qui seront données moi j'ai clairement
annoncé la couleur je suis favorable à
l'europe et je suis prêt à ratifier main
street sous certaines conditions
mais je le répète encore une fois pas en
allant sur les estrades avec des
responsables politiques dont je ne
partage pas globalement la philosophie
politique ni même la philosophie
européenne
merci mme veil dernière question alain
juppé est ce que vous vous souvenez des
termes de la petite phrase qui vous
avait valu le prix d'excellence du club
de l'humour politique en 88 il ya quatre
ans vous faire une confidence je les
oublier
alors j'ai voulu rappeler parce qu'elle
est parfaitement d'actualité vous aviez
déclaré françois mitterrand et le
spécialiste du piège à consensus voilà
alors le club de l'humour politique
précisément a décerné ses trophées pour
cette année prix d'excellence pour 92 à
kofi yamgnane parlant ainsi de son
collègue du gouvernement louis le pensec
nous sommes tous de breton avait il dit
mais lui et d'avant la marée noire et
moi d'après premier prix à christine
boutin député udf des yvelines lors d'un
débat extrêmement sérieuse sur la
bioéthique
il ne faudrait pas que celui qui vient
de donner son sperme s'en lave les mains
fin de citation retour sur sérieuse avec
de nouvelles manifestations de
protestation des agriculteurs contre la
réforme de la pac la politique agricole
commune
c'est à toulouse et à versailles que ces
manifestations ont été les plus
spectaculaires commentaires elisabeth sd
à toulouse tout les rocades bloqué ce
matin par les agriculteurs du cdj à et
de la coordination rurale de haute
garonne
ils protestent contre la réforme de la
politique agricole commune et veulent
rencontrer leur député indépendant
maisons laprise fois qu'ils sont pas
intelligents mais ils ne savent pas ce
qui se passe sur le terrain des check
points de base à versailles une
cinquantaine de tracteurs devant le
château et des milliers de manifestants
venus du nord et du bassin parisien
à l'appel des organisations syndicales
qui veulent prouver à leurs troupes
qu'elles ne baisse pas les bras
même si elles ont pris acte de la
politique agricole commune il leur faut
canaliser les revendications face à la
coordination rurale
plus radical qui veut faire bouger les
campagnes en yougoslavie poursuite des
bombardements de sarajevo cette nuit le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu a approuvé
le principe de l'envoi de casques bleus
chargés de prendre le contrôle de
l'aéroport de cette ville afin d'assurer
la chimio à peu près normal de l'aide
humanitaire dans la capitale de bosnie
la france a d'ailleurs proposé de
fournir une grande partie de ce millier
d'hommes qui devrait se déployer très
prochainement sur place
en tout cas à l'embargo décrété par les
nations unies il ya quelques jours
commence à faire sentir ses effets en
serbie où l'essence est rationnée depuis
ce matin reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux
gilles rabin alain du bas
il découvre que pendant leur absence il
semaines de vacances en hongrie
le prix de l'essence a doublé il
découvre en même temps que cette essence
est rationnée distribué au compte goûte
chaque jour et pour un seul trajet c'est
pour l'instant le seul effet
spectaculaire de l'embargo voté par les
nations unies contre la serbie que la
crise économique est presque un an de
guerre ont déjà pratiquement ruiné le
pays
l'embargo c'est vrai nous achever le
peuple va souffrir encore plus et le
peuple serbe lui n'est pas coupable
85% des places sur le mois dernier en
serbie et en plus ça n'arrivera pas la
guerre
l'embargo ce n'est qu'un jeu entre les
puissants lassitude des serbes
le boulanger de belgrade et son apprenti
la voit grandir jour après jour seul le
sucre l'huile et la lessive mans mais
personne n'achète car les gens n'ont
plus d'argent et depuis longtemps
c'est injuste mais résistera
on gardera le moral regardez autour de
vous les français nous ont trahis sages
comprend pas les français nous tourne le
dos il se couche devant les allemands
les américains et n'a jamais vu
sadristes tromper de victimes - ils
voulaient m'égorger en croatie j'ai
échappé aux fascistes c'est notre pays
on en a pas d'autre qu'est ce que vous
allez faire nous attaquer nous bombarder
les allemands ils ont perdu deux guerres
aujourd'hui il rêve de revanche avec
leur marque ils sont restés l'europe et
monsieur bush lui il a acheté des
nations unies qui deviennent des
allemands je pourrai manger ma famille
23 personnes tuées pour les piments 42
par eux et les oustachis croates
je suis le seul rescapé
et voilà qu'aujourd'hui je dois de
nouveau vivre ça
les serbes en veulent au monde entier et
d'abord à la france comme en témoigne ce
monument crêpés de noir ils ne
parviennent plus à surmonter ni leur
passion ni la reine ni leur rancune ni
leur regret peut-être parce qu'il sent
confusément qu'ils n'ont pas su défendre
la cause serbe
eq avec l'embargo quoi qu'il arrive
désormais ils ont déjà perdu la guerre
cnn a désormais un concurrent européen
euronews la chaîne européenne
d'information continue par satellite est
née officiellement ce matin à lyon en
présence des dirigeants de 11 sociétés
publiques de radio télévision dont hervé
bourges pour antenne 2 et fr3 euronews
diffusera à partir de janvier 93 en cinq
langues l'anglais l'allemand l'espagnol
l'italien et bien sûr le français des 93
donc ces images pourront être reçus dans
23 millions de foyers européens près
d'amboise un agriculteur excédé par le
passage d'adolescents dans ses cultures
a tiré avec un fusil de chasse sur un
groupe de 11
jeunes en blessant cinq plus ou moins
grièvement reportage a nourri christian
leroux sur les raisons de ce drame
quartier de la verrerie une cité sous
haute surveillance
une cité au milieu des champs population
cosmopolite immeuble refait à neuf
de gros efforts de réhabilitation peu de
chômage jusqu'ici peu de délinquance
pourtant les jeunes ont le sentiment
d'être montrée du doigt par le reste de
la ville c'est un quartier l'étranger
alors dès qu'il ya un truc qui va passer
les étrangers c'est la verrie tout de
suite
en fait même si c'est pas la vérité on
est tout de suite accusé pour se rendre
en ville
les jeunes passent par ce chemin privé
un raccourci c'est là que cinq d'entre
eux ont été blessés par des agriculteurs
rivières depuis longtemps les riverains
se plaignent culture saccagé chapardage
n'a pas beaucoup avec cyanose à
poubelles la plume d avoir des petits et
puis le ch jouera pas passer d'une
culture et puis il ya fermé aux
écureuils poule ça traîne poulter et
rennes et rennes alors que bien qu'il
fasse quelque chose
on n'est pas tranquille ici on est tous
des vieux ici
en haute mer il faut peut-être donner
quelque chose se passe quelque chose
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que l'on fasse
on n'a pas de on a quatre policiers
municipaux vont pas les envoyer toute la
journée je dirais par là alors qu'il ya
d'autres problèmes dans le tas sans dans
brèves elle a l'impression comme ses
voisins que les voleurs de poules
peuvent ici commettre leur larcin en
toute impunité au tour tout de suite à
l'événement de la soirée le meeting
commun de ces les stages vous tout de
suite de rejoindre sur place rachid
arhab rachid se passe en direct
madame guigou est en train de parler
actuellement et valéry giscard d'estaing
se trouve je crois derrière le rideau il
attend tout simplement je crois par
pouliguen que le ministre ait fini son
intervention ils vont donc se rencontrer
dans quelques instants
je vous propose de nous d'essayer de
combler ces quelques secondes en vous
disant un petit peu l'ambiance qui règne
ici
vous m'entendez oui oui donc une
ambiance tout à fait calme une ambiance
de de studieuses dans un endroit où
habituellement ces deux rues plutôt des
rencontres sportives il s'agit ici d'un
d'un gymnase il est juste qu'elle a
peut-être que impatience au début quand
les organisateurs ans a annoncé qu'il
fallait attendre l'arrivée de valéry
giscard d'estaing qui se trouve toujours
derrière son rideau et qui devrait venir
s'installer dans quelques secondes
logiquement non pas face à madame guigou
mais à ses côtés il ne sera séparé de la
ministre des affaires européennes que
par jean françois poncet qui est
l'organisateur des
l'arrêt de ce débat qui s'est présentée
à paris ici
les applaudissements la semaine biblique
ses tableaux 10 actuellement et je crois
que nous avons pu voir assister à
l'arrivée de valéry giscard d'estaing en
direct l'événement comme vous le disiez
cet événement qui fait tant jaser à
paris voilà vous y assister en direct
mon cher bruno j'espère que vous êtes
content qui te fait deux morts à l'invs
autre caméraman de déplacer un tout
petit peu la camsa combat nous allons
essayer mais mone moi me déplacer pour
que vous puissiez voir le président
arrivé et répondre à cette fameuse
question
va-t-il serrer la main madame guigou
nous allons bientôt avoir cette ré cette
réponse
tout cela se fait un petit peu dans la
précipitation les organisateurs il faut
le dire une eau ont été dépassé par
l'importance médiatique de la couverture
de cette cette réunion alors pour
l'instant à un petit peu de suspense
madame guigou a enlevé son micro comme
si elle avait terminé son intervention
mais malgré tout il semble que le
ministre des affaires européennes va
rester dans la salle pendant que
monsieur giscard d'estaing viendra ici
je le répète bruno il ne s'agit pas d'un
dialogue entre eux il s'agit d'un débat
organisé ici à sélestat qui est animée
par plusieurs journalistes un débat qui
est censé donner un lieu un certain
nombre d' échange de vues et non pas à
des des discours je dirais
officiel donc il s'agit effectivement
aux européens de gauche comme de droite
est d'essayer de dire parfois ils
s'entendent ici et là calme
si la patience au bout
et je ne sais pas
alors j'étais un petit peu de radios
dans ce cas là
beaucoup de photographes et peut-être le
président il caché derrière lançant très
souvent dont il ménage ses effets valéry
giscard d'estaing se trouve derrière moi
et surtout derrière les photographes qui
en ce sens en ce moment entre
d'officialiser d'immortaliser cette
image qui est donc tant fait jaser à
paris j'espère que non quelques secondes
mais chers confrères qui cherche à faire
la une de tous les quotidiens demain
nous laisserons nous si avoir la chance
de savoir si c'est bien monsieur valéry
giscard d'estaing qui est arrivé moi je
le vois par ailleurs sur un autre écran
de contrôle
si je ne peux se dit sereine sur ce fut
un vrai événement là ça serait un vrai
événement mais je crois que je peux vous
confirmer d'ores et déjà qu'il s'agit
bien de valéry giscard d'estaing et ici
il faut le rappeler en tant que
président du mouvement européen
international et non pas en tant que
responsable politique français
je crois que dans quelques instants
voilà que nous allons pouvoir enfin
pourquoi vous donnez l'image que vous
attendiez mon cher bruno et vous rendre
l'antenne ensuite voilà vous allez
découvrir c'est lui valéry giscard
d'estaing installé à un peu
deux maîtres d'elisabeth guigou voilà je
crois que vous avez eu l'essentiel vous
cher bruno le débat ici va commencer à
débattre café peut trés voilà le digou
qui a été pas mal applaudit également
tout à l'heure je peux simplement vous
signaler que la prochaine rencontre de
ce genre aura lieu samedi à nevers à la
fiche pierre bérégovoy et françois
léotard
mais voilà c'est bien sûr nous
entendrons les principaux extraits de
l'intervention de l'ancien président de
la république dans le dernier journal à
20h45 d'indy journal présenté par daniel
duigou les bleus partent demain la
conquête de l'europe l'équipe de france
inaugurera en effet l'euro 92 de
m'asseoir en direct sur antenne 2 je
vous le rappelle en affrontant l'équipe
hôte les suédois le sélectionneur michel
platini a annoncé ce matin la
composition du onze tricolore peu de
surprise manuel amoros a été titularisé
en défense et pascal vahirua participera
bien sûr à la ligne d'attaqué aux côtés
bien évidemment de jean pierre papin
tout va bien pour notre cher numéro 9
les chevilles la tête tout tout tout
comme vannes ou confirmés de l'un de nos
envoyés spéciaux en suède olivier rey
mais si il faut bien en parler de cette
cheville son état inquiète et tous les
supporters des bleus le rôle de jpp est
des plus importants et l'équipe de
france a besoin d'un papin en pleine
possession de ses moyens pour bien
débuter dans cet euro 92 c'est pourquoi
les médecins se sont relayés pour
soigner cette chenille
le diagnostic est plutôt rassurant
jean pierre qui avait son problème de
cheville de cartilage de chevilly les
choses évoluent aussi de façon
satisfaisante
je pense que maintenant il doit être
complètement rassuré par rapport à
l'état de son état de santé
à l'entraînement pas passer souvent
préparés à l'écart du groupe en
solitaire il s'est ménagé évitant les
contacts les chocs ce match d'ouverture
contre la semaine peut en effet se
révéler capital pour la suite de la
compétition
il faut prendre des points parce
qu'après on peut gérer on peut
éventuellement en gagnant un match on a
qualifié donc pour nous ce moment le
plus important
il ne lui restait plus que demain à
marquer un but comme l'autre juin contre
les pays bas 1 but à la jpp pour le
bonheur de l'équipe de france
demain en direct à 20h sur antenne 2
dans quelques minutes un était glacée un
téléfilm signé bernard giraudeau sur un
sujet difficile l'euthanasie thème du
débat animé par claude sérillon ensuite
ce soit dans raison de plus comme tous
les mardis dernier journal vers 23h45 en
compagnie de daniel duigou
bon anniversaire à barbara dans un
instant donc la météo avec laurent
cabrol n'oublie pas donc demain
rendez-vous exceptionnellement à 19h30
pour le journal en raison donc de la
diffusion à 20 heures précises du
premier match de l'équipe de france en
championnat d'europe des nations avec
une page spéciale animée par caen
rissani en direct de suède excellente
soirée à toutes et à tous merci à dom
piste rapide cet après midi à chantilly
où se disputait le tiercé
ils sont 18 au départ des 2000 mètres de
la piste du jockey club à 300 mètres du
but d'elina kazakh marron et bleu vient
de prendre la tête poursuivi par watt
qui faisant aux jaune et rouge incognita
grenat coutures jaunes se rapproche vite
en pleine piste à 100 mètres du disque
et li na a course gagnée devant
incognita watts qui venaient d'attaquer
par lesdits prospects casaque rose et
rikitea en rouge et gris monte à la
perfection par jean michel bru ledit
stellina remporte enfin sa course le 17
incognita fini le plus fort devant le
haut soit gift qui résistent de justesse
à l'attack du 12 lady prospects gérard
dubrac amène le gaz rikitea à la
cinquième place rapport moyen seulement
pour des combinaisons qui n'était
pourtant pas facile
trouvé par 13 parieurs le quinté plus
dans l'ordre rapporte 300 milles et 50
francs pour différents
face cure fil aux poteaux poursuivi par
les trois représentants de l'écurie
chalus la toque blanc et bleu d'asthme
hussein s'est envolé finalement river
majesty est deuxième devant millau
robertino bormio est en tête depuis le
début à ce qu'eto'o est encore dernier
acteur français kazakh noir et jaune est
très gênée à ski et autres ouvrent le
passage clou sur place ses adversaires
et le favori star of cause n est
deuxième devant lots ping succès du
rothschild ping qui rose monté par as he
hussein dans la première course de
forget tu me monter par eric
saint-martin dans la cinquième de head
quarters confié à eric legris dans la
sixième
thierry jarnet conserve la tête du
championnat de france des jockeys deux
points devant norbert jean-pierre
asmussen restent troisièmes fouroulou a
tenté en vain de se débarrasser de son
apprenti inexpérimenté mais patrick par
dix a déjà une bonne assiette les
courses plates sont à evry demain images
et commentaires dans le journal des
courses à l'heure habituelle
le refus de 92 en direct sur antenne 2
fr3 suède france un match décisif pour
le commandant le platini qui rêve de
remporter à nouveau le plus prestigieux
trophées européens pays-bas écosse
gullit van basten riches gardent les
tenant du titre face à une redoutable
équipe écossaise avec schneider et
eurocard mastercard
tu es tranche m 10 juin à 20h15 sur
antenne 2 pays-bas écosse vendredi 12
juin à 17h15 sur antenne 2 antenne 2 fr3
le plus grand terrain de sport
fiat présente les estivales décoration
exclusive vitres teintées toits ouvrants
radiocassette stereo panda
thébaux les estivales de filtration des
voitures qui auraient les vacances
incorporé
bonsoir à vous tous madame mademoiselle
monsieur il avait en météo comme comme
en politique
le temps est à l'orage l'orage les
orages se sont propagées sur quasiment
toute la france de le revoir sur l'image
satellite exactement où ils se situent
et quand ce type de temps ne devrait
perdurer dans la journée de demain
envoyés sur l'hémisphère nord il y a une
grosse zone nuageuse sur l'atlantique et
devrait nous concerne et dans les jours
à venir mais pas dans l'immédiat
dans l'immédiat celle qui nous concerne
c'est celle ci nous allons d'ailleurs
nous rapprocher grâce au satellite et
constater ici il y à un enroulement
nuageux c'est une un centre
dépressionnaire qui génère cette
remontée de nuages d'air chaud et humide
les orages étaient présents sur le sud
de dijon le sud de la france en général
ils vont se caler demain sur les régions
de l'est comme nous allons d'ailleurs
l'apercevoir et le voir tout de suite
sur cette carte du temps prévu pour la
journée l'envoyons puisqu'il ya
plusieurs zones
ici c'est le temps orageux c'est à dire
sur la franche comté la région rhône
alpes la côte d'azur la provence les
alpes mais aussi l'auvergne sur le
languedoc-roussillon tramontane va se la
tramontane va souffler assez forte avec
une manière assez fort avec donc des
averses
et puis le beau temps se situera sur la
bretagne les pays de loire et la basse
tandis qu'elle ne connaît point nommé si
le pays basque avec un ciel souvent
obscurs si les frontières là vous savez
frontière franco belge est franco russe
luxembourgeoise partout ailleurs un ciel
d'alternance avec une prédominance nuage
ça n'est pas simple mais il fallait
faire dans le détail pour que vous soyez
informé vous qui habitez dans toutes ces
régions les températures maintenant pour
le petit matin entre 9 et 15 degrés du
nord au sud
au petit matin avec un 8 degrés sur
limoges qui sera la ville la plus
fraîche l'après midi le thermomètre on a
tendance à se tasser à 10 ans a baissé
très nettement entre 16 et 21 22 au nord
et entre 14 et 14 animaux jusqu'à 22 au
sud 22 degrés vous constatez avec moi
ces poches d'air relativement frais 16
degrés soit biar et 17 sur la pointe
bretagne il faut se dépêcher le clin
d'oeil de la météo c'est un clin d'oeil
frissons rien à voir avec la température
là c'est un peu la chair de poule
regardons ensemble ce qui se passe aux
etats unis
lorsqu'il ya des meetings aériens c'est
fabuleux d'avoir bon monde
bien sûr enfin une façon de monter ce
qui monte à l'intérieur et ceux qui
montent à l'extérieur voici
elle reste maintenant à donner le
frisson à ceux qui sont en bas
regardez attention at il convenu de
monsieur non c'est ainsi tout proche
dire que dans cet état des usa les
meetings ont des allures de voltige
aérienne un peu à l'image de ce qui se
passe dans les cirques et regardez cet
atterrissage extraordinaire avant de
nous séparer car nous sommes pressés par
le temps bien entendu
regardez le monsieur va atterrir sur la
voiture alors qu'il restait trop cher
l'avion vitesse de l'avion et de la
voiture 120 kilomètres heure on décroche
le monsieur est l'avion bye bye superbe
voilà merci de nous avoir suivis demain
matin sophie davant nous jeter un coup
d'oeil sur l'éphéméride nous fêterons
margaret et landry en ce mercredi 10
juin
bonne soirée sur antenne 2 avant vous
tous
quel est le plus gros transfert de
l'année en matière de tiercé panorama le
journal au coeur de la course
programme de qualité ce soir à vincennes
l'épreuve d'ouverture a été une proie
facile pour son favori vahiné casaque
bleue qui malgré une courte hésitation
départ s'est rapidement installé au
commandement
comme vous le voyez le domine très
sûrement végétarien qui lui rendait 25
mètres et pasco de tartifume kazakh
blanche quatrième venus de folio n'a pas
été très heureuse dans l'ultime virage
récente acquisition de daniel
wildenstein vahiné et son jeune driver
nicolas roussel ont survolé ce prix e
crac
il ne devrait pas en rester là les
trotteurs du prix est qu là nous ont
offert un final superbe la victoire
revenant tout à la fin al zarkaoui john
pourtant encore loin des premiers à 500
mètres du but et qui a tracé une ligne
droite de toute beauté pour venir
dominer at de la cordier en rouge et
halcyon de pouline casaque bleue qui
n'ont pu être départagés par la
photographie à mission se classe
quatrième c'est un véritable cavalier
seul qui a réalisé habib est dans cette
épreuve sous la selle assez vite en tête
malgré son handicap de 25 mètres il n'a
alors fait qu'une bouchée de ses
adversaires l'emportant de loin traces
island clarbec et agile castellet
ancenis et atouts du close et avait
décliné la lutte dans ce semi classique
pour quatre ans vite mettre de la
première place le favori artistes du but
assure un train régulier mais peu rapide
et accélère peu après l'entrée de la
ligne d'arrivée pour aussitôt se mettre
hors de portée de ses rivaux
rien de brion le long de la corde qui
tentait de le suivre sans lait 20 min
droite ce dont profite à ce destin pour
se classer second devant annie chéri
aiglons d'eau et axes des stars
artiste du but et nicolas roussel ont
confirmé leur victoire dans le critérium
des 4 ans il signe ce soir une seconde
victoire pour monsieur wild hunt stein
bénéficiant d'un bon engagement union 2g
en a profité pour renouer avec une
victoire qui la fuyait depuis fort
longtemps
venu en tête dans le dernier tournant
elle n'est nullement inquiété par tu as
paca grand l'animatrice de cette épreuve
et irigo ulf ans n'avait pas couru alain
sionneau partenaires d'union de j'ai
tout de suite à l'image l'autostart
était au rendez vous du prix urd à
épreuve dédoubler réservé aux poulains
de 3 ans dans la première d'entre elles
guy zibi kazakh grenat a tenté tout au
long de la ligne droite d'attaqué baïkal
mais ce dernier s'est montré intraitable
auteur d'un dernier kilomètre de toute
beauté globenet se classe 3e brio
d'oeuvre y étaient non-partants raymond
david peut être satisfait il tient en
baïkal un poulain de qualités marines de
la mode s'est abstenu dans ce groupe b
du prix urd à coeuve a remporté
nettement black hat ou and athletic fils
de florestan toujours bien placé
bleuettes répond on va s'assurer
facilement le premier accessit détacher
de bobigny 2 6 et baron de boogie black
hat ou très entouré après sa victoire
deux journaux des courses demain à 20h35
pour la réunion d'evry et en fin de
soirée pour celle de vichy
bonsoir à tous
pierre ses panoramas le journal au coeur
de la course
bonsoir et d'abord les titres de ce
journal première journée de la visite
officielle de la reine elizabeth à paris
à commencer par la remontée de l'avenue
des champs elysées en grande pompe
embouteillages monstres à toulouse à
cause de la manif des jeunes
agriculteurs de haute garonne
les barrages ont été levés après la
promesse de pouvoir rencontrer les élus
locaux crise au sein de l'opposition à
propos de maastricht le rpr lance un
ultimatum à l'udf en lui interdisant de
tenir meeting avec la gauche
l'événement de la soirée c'est valéry
giscard d'estaing au côté d'elisabeth
guigou ministre socialiste pour défendre
le traité de maastricht
l'ex président a donc passé outre
l'avertissement du rpr lors d'une
réunion publique à sélestat dans le
bas-rhin sur place olivier lerner
elisabeth guigou est arrivée la première
pas vraiment décontractée
valéry giscard d'estaing plus souriant
sûr de réaliser un joli coup médiatique
était aux anges
il n'y a pas eu de réponse du berger à
la bergère valéry giscard d'estaing a
préféré ignorer les sévères attaques de
jacques chirac
cela je vous arrête tout de suite moi
j'ai pas de pourparlers de la politique
la politique même si vous parlez le
traité de maastricht
alors si vous voulez m'entraîner en
dehors il faut sortir de cette salle
aller ailleurs et en en parlant
autrement je participe à une campagne
d'explication
valéry giscard d'estaing sur sa réserve
c'est étrangement elisabeth guigou qui a
osé s'adresser au rpr absents on veut
nous faire croire que l'on est pour
l'europe mais qu'on est contre le traité
de maastricht alors moi je pose la
question à ceux qui disent cela
est ce que vous croyez que vous pouvez
faire l'europe tout seul est ce que vous
croyez monsieur seguin que vous pouvez
être là sur votre chaise à nous agiter
et en disant moi je veux faire l'europe
différemment si vous trouvez pas des
européens pour la faire avec vous la
prépa le ton du débat est resté très
poli très technique mais en fin de
soirée le président de l'udf s'est senti
obligé de faire écouter sa différence
lorsque la campagne du référendum sera
engagée c'est à dire sans doute la
presse kolo dit après l'été eh bien il
est évident que chacun fera campagne
sous ses propres couleurs
ils ne se sont pas plus à lui et au
départ qu'à l'arrivée il ne fallait peut
être pas en faire trop pour ne pas
exciter davantage un rpr plutôt jaloux
de cette idylle neuf mois donc avant les
législatives l'opposition risque
d'exploser en morceaux hier soir le rpr
avait lancé un ultimatum au responsable
de l'udf
pas question de tenir des réunions
communes avec la gauche dans ces
conditions le meeting de sélestat risque
d'avoir des conséquences rachid arhab
l'événement a donc eu lieu et même s'il
n'a duré que l'espace d'une photo cet
événement ne fera vraiment pas plaisir à
jacques chirac
ouah pas les rues giscard d'estaing à la
même tribune k ministre de françois
mitterrand
cela laissera forcément des traces au
sein de l'opposition
certes le président de l'udf a refusé à
sélestat de polémiquer à distance avec
son alter ego du rpr mais on peut penser
que les comptes se régleront un jour ou
l'autre et certainement ailleurs qu à
sélestat on ne peut pas encore dire que
l'irréparable se soit véritablement
produits
de l'opposition mais en fait tout de
même il en va de la politique comme de
la vie de tous les jours
lorsque dans un couple l'un des deux
partenaires décident de s'offrir des
escapades de temps en temps avec un
amant ou une maîtresse c'est selon il
fait toujours cela au risque du divorce
aux yeux du rpr la rencontre entre
l'opposition et la gauche sur le traité
de maastricht est contre nature
invité de notre journal de 20 heures
alain juppé en a expliqué les raisons
nous n'avons pas la même conception de
l'europe que les socialistes et c'est
tellement vrai qu'il y à peine 10 jours
à l'assemblée nationale nous avons
essayé ils ont presque réussi de
censurer la politique agricole
européenne du gouvernement alors à quoi
riment ces meetings communs sinon à
prendre le risque de troubler les
électrices et les électeurs vous savez
moi je suis pour l'europe
je suis prêt à ratifier maïs riche mais
en aucune manière à donner un coup de
main monsieur mitterrand parce que je
pense que plutôt les socialistes
quitteront le pouvoir mieux ça vaudra
pour mon pays au sénat toujours pas
d'accord entre le rpr et l'udf pour
reprendre les travaux sur la révision de
la constitution nécessaires à la
ratification de maastricht sur place
véronique saint-aulaye fallait-il
reprendre le débat de la révision
constitutionnelle nécessaires à la
ratification d'un traité qui a perdu
l'un de ses signataires les socialistes
et l'udf ont répondu oui comme un seul
homme les communistes et le rpr ont
clamé non d'une seule voix les wii était
majoritaire les sénateurs se sont donc
retrouvés après le dîner mais si les
orateurs se succèdent à la tribune
les tractations se poursuivent dans
l'hémicycle cette nuit une trentaine
d'orateurs vont se succéder pour dire à
tour de rôle tous le bien où tout le mal
qu'il pense du traité de maastricht
mais demain après midi l'amendement sur
le vote des ressortissants
communautaires revient sur le tapis
c'est alors que se fera ou non la
fracture rpr d'un côté udf de l'autre à
moins à moins que le feuilleton de
l'opposition ne connaisse un nouveau
rebondissement de l'europe il en a été
aussi question avec la reine elizabeth
lors d'un dîner offert en son honneur au
palais de l'elysée la reine s'est
exprimé en français avec son charmant
accent
la soirée s'est ensuite terminée au
louvre par des illuminations
exceptionnel bernard lebrun
gastronomie et politique au palais
présidentiel pour un dîner de gala
réunissant 200 convives en l'honneur de
la reine elizabeth
au menu foie gras en gelée au sauternes
petit carré d'agneau aux figues rôties
singh lacets elysées le tout arrosé de
château yquem et de châteaux la cad ou
978 invités politiques d'honneur et qui
gère sur ce soir jacques chaban delmas
raymond barre et l'objectif coiffure de
son diadème la reine elizabeth en robe
blanche r jean ping ne semble pas trop
fatigué de sa première journée de ces
jours elle semble même ravis de se
retrouver vingt ans après sa visite
georges pompidou sous les plafonds de
l'elysée dans la salle parmi notre
attendant les traditionnels discours
catherine deneuve lecomte d'orléans
pierre bergé ainsi que charlotte
rampling
quelles que soient leurs inclinations
elles vont du plus au moins nos
gouvernements ont lancé le combat pour
l'europe avec le même désir de
convaincre et de réussir l'empreinte
indélébile dans la france a marqué la
communauté n'est pas toujours
confortable aussi dans les institutions
repose sur des traditions différentes
la tradition anglo saxonne et qu'un peu
à la tradition latine en europe ce que
l'huile est au vinaigre
il faut les deux pour faire la sauce
sinon la salade et mal assaisonner
vinaigrette donc il était jadis question
d'entente cordiale entre l'angleterre et
la france
maintenant que tous les ingrédients sont
réunis par la reine on pourra désormais
dire que la mayonnaise a pris entre
elizabeth 2 et françois mitterrand un
couple qui s'est immédiatement
transporté au palais du louvre
après ce dîner en compagnie de danielle
mitterrand et qui prince consort
philippe d
une visite nocturne pour assister à
l'embrasement de la cour napoléon et de
la pyramide cours majestueuse dont la
restauration viennent à peine d'être
achevée et a été officieusement inauguré
ce soir par cette cérémonie royale
le maire du mans robert jarry a été
inculpé par le juge renaud van ruymbeke
dans la sphère du financement du ps et
du pc dans la sarthe
coup de colère des jeunes agriculteurs
de la haute garonne
ils ont bloquaient toulouse en dressant
une demi douzaine de barrages sur les
principaux axes résultats et bien c'est
une belle pagaille dorothée olliéric
véritable blocus aujourd'hui à toulouse
où les agriculteurs ont dressé des
barrages sur les routes pour protester
contre la politique agricole commune
au total une centaine de voix ont été
bloqués par des tracteurs provoquant une
des plus belle pagaille que la ville
rose est connu dans l'après midi on
apprenait que les huit député de
haute-garonne avait accepté de
rencontrer les jeunes agriculteurs
demain à 14h30 les principaux barrages
ont donc été levée dans la soirée remise
en liberté des deux anciens responsables
les girondins de bordeaux claude bez et
didier couécou ils sont inculpés d'abus
de confiance de faux et usage de faux
leur incarcération avait été jugée
nécessaire par le juge d'instruction le
temps d'effectuer un certain nombre de
vérifications
mais le magistrat n'a pas pu interroger
l'intermédiaire yougoslave bas-rhin
soupçonné d'avoir été la pierre
angulaire dans le transfert de certains
joueurs
cinq ans après l'accident de télésiège
de luz ardiden dans les hautes pyrénées
le procès des responsables présumés
s'est ouvert ce matin au tribunal
correctionnel de tarbes les neuf
prévenus qui comparaissent pour
homicides et blessures involontaires se
sont vus reprocher des fautes
d'imprudence de non observation du
règlement ou encore d'inattention lors
de cette première journée de débats les
inculpés se sont censés être envoyé les
responsabilités l'accident avait fait
six morts et 38 blessés graves
aujourd'hui la majorité des victimes ont
été indemnisées les combats sarajevo ces
quatre derniers jours n'ont jamais été
aussi violent bilan vingt morts 340
blessés et la grande majorité de la
capitale détruite par les bombardements
hier l'armée bosniaque a mené une contre
offensive ce qui lui a permis de
reprendre plusieurs collines occupé
jusqu'à maintenant par les serbes
aujourd'hui retour au calme la
population a pu sortir des caves et des
abris les premiers observateurs de l'onu
devrait arriver dès mercredi pour
assurer la protection de l'aéroport
mille casques bleus sont attendus par la
suite jérusalem a décidé de faciliter
encore plus l'entrée en israël des
travailleurs palestiniens de la bande de
gaza après quatorze jours de fermeture
alger c'est toujours la tension trois
policiers ont été tués aujourd'hui par
un groupe armé non identifié
passons maintenant aux sports avec le
suspense de la transat en solitaire vent
de 30 noeuds mer forte
il a choisi l'option la plus au nord et
ça lui réussit paul vatine le havre est
de 34 ans a donc pris la tête de la
transat anglaise à la barre de haute
normandie
florence arthaud sur pierre 1er de
serbie a été pointée à la troisième
position devancé par frima gaz et
laurent bourgnon ont fait la transat a
perdu le tenant du titre philippe poupon
contraint à l'abandon après la rupture
de sa dérive
mauvaise journée pour le club de
football nantais la ligue nationale a
décidé sa relégation en deuxième
division
motif sa situation financière
catastrophique 60 millions de francs de
déficit
nantes a décidé de faire appel l'année
dernière ce sont les girondins de
bordeaux qui avait dû subir cette
humiliation
à la veille du match d'ouverture de
l'euro 92 qui opposera la suède à la
france les bleus ont fini leur
entraînement
pas d'effervescence platini a même
ménagé ses joueurs à cause de la chaleur
enfin la composition de l'équipe a été
annoncée seule surprise la sélection de
vahirua préféré à péret de l'événement
demain sur antenne 2 à suivre à partir
de 20 heures
coup d'oeil sur les marchés boursiers et
à paris marché déprimé après le long
week-end de la pentecôte -0 67 % à wall
street c'est également de la baisse
ironique ce projet
c'était une mauvaise séance à wall
street ce soir lundi dow jones a perdu
plus de 1% ou 1 34 point à 3369 points
comme à la bourse de paris ce matin les
investisseurs attendent la publication
des prochains a dit économiques
américains et notamment l'inflation qui
devrait être publié jeudi ses chiffres
détermineront la future politique de la
banque centrale américaine le dollar lui
reste ferme face à l'ensemble des
devises le billet vert cote 1 2 tu
marques 59 20 et 5 francs 35 85 en
france ce soit le gouvernement vient
d'autoriser pechiney à vendre l'ensemble
de ses activités dans le nucléaire
l'opération leur apportera à près de 2
milliards de francs 2 milliards pour
pechiney les bijoux de famille resteront
quand même dans le secteur public
puisque c'est la cogema et framatome qui
rachète pour plus de détails vous pouvez
bien sûr consulter votre minitel en
tapant le 36 15 codes et quads
voilà ce journal est terminée prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité
c'est à 6h30 avec télé matin à 13 heures
philippe lefait exceptionnellement à
19h30 c'est bruno masure car à 20 heures
nous avons rendez vous en direct pour
l'euro 92 avec le match france contre
suède très bonne nuit
e
remis à vous tous madame mademoiselle
monsieur l'animation est à son comble
des perturbation traverse la france
à l'avant et bien il ya une agitation
rageuse à l'arrière une autre invitation
orageuse bref ça s'agite dans tous les
sens si le temps pour la journée de
mercredi avec vous le constatez et bien
voyons dans le détail très orageux dans
toutes ces régions là c'est à dire sur
la franche comté la région rhône alpes
la côte d'azur la provence des alpes y
compris sur le vern
sur le languedoc et le roussillon des
vents vent jusqu'à 70 km par heure sur
le sud-ouest un temps pas très folichon
quand même des éclaircies puisque nous
poursuivons le tour de france sur la
bretagne les pays de loire et la basse
normandie
quelques ondées le long des côtes
franco-belge et franco-luxembourgeoise
partout ailleurs un ciel souvent couvert
avec des nuages abondant voilà nous
avons essayé de découper la france en
tranches les températures du petit matin
entre 9 et 15 degrés sans commentaire ce
sont exactement les mêmes que celles que
nous vivons en ce moment et dans le
courant de l'après-midi am léger
fléchissement vous l'avez noté 19 en
ile-de-france 17 dans le centre celle
sur la presqu'île du cotentin à 21° à
mulhouse 14 degrés seulement à limoges
où la l'ars la baisse bes bien voilà
pour ceux d'entre vous qui voyagent ou
constatez avec moi que il ne fera pas
bon sur le nord de l'europe
ulf ragots en revanche sur l'afrique du
nord entre 23 25 et 27 degrés sur rabat
alger et tunis et 27° à athènes cours en
ce moment il fait très chaud les
températures étant donné pour l'ensemble
des pays européens retourne en ouvert
l'éphéméride en ce mercredi 10 juin
nous fêterons landry et margaret tient
dans carette
merci beaucoup d'avoir suivi de ce
bulletin météo est bonne et à vous tous
sur antenne de revoir
et
aujourd'hui le 10 juin le 10 juin 11 190
frédéric barberousse empereur du saint
empire germanique se noie un croisade
est à l'eau
1949 parution de 1984 de george orwell
big brother is watching you 1967 un de
la guerre des six jours
dyan triomphe les territoires sont
amochés